[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
the covid surge in texas is largely
driven by unvaccinated americans but
there is growing concern the migrant
crisis
may be complicating the issue the city
of mcallen texas says more than seven
thousand migrants who tested positive
for covet have been processed since
february
including more than fifteen hundred just
this past week
most do go straight into quarantine
maria viral got exclusive access to one
temporary emergency shelter set up to
test and treat migrants who have coveted
she joins us from mcallen texas maria
good morning
well good morning this morning i'm
actually standing under the ancel dues
international bridge that leads into
mexico with
a purpose because if you take a look
from the sky and right behind me you're
going to see
a makeshift processing site that is run
by border patrol
so many people are crossing into the u.s
right now they just have no room to put
them in actual buildings
and with covert in mind decision makers
believe that this what you're looking at
is the best option they have the
enormity of the country's immigration
issues
is on full display underneath this busy
stretch of highway
the site run by customs and border
protection measures
well over the length of a football field
with room to grow
once agents process these migrants most
will board buses and end up here
a local park turned into a temporary
tent city
run by the city of mcallen and catholic
charities
but the first thing that happened
straight off the bus is
kova testing
catholic charities director sister norma
pimentel says
migrants testing positive for covid has
been overwhelming
but it got to a point where that that
space is not even that readily available
because
there's so many of them in the last
three weeks mcallen has seen over 1800
migrants a day
prompting mayor javier villalobos to
order a declaration of emergency
it is very burdensome for our county our
city
and we don't budget for this we don't
deal with immigration we shouldn't
across the entire southwest border 210
000 migrant apprehensions
were reported for july a 21-year high
that's caught the attention of
conservative leaders across the country
if you just want to hopscotch across
that border
they don't care about kovid they're
letting you straight in
a cbs news medical expert says the
coveted positive cases from across the
border are relatively small
and attribute the latest surge across
the u.s to the delta variant
low vaccination rates and roll back
restrictions
but local officials in texas are already
growing concerned
initially i didn't see it as a problem
because it was under control so i saw no
correlation
between the increase in covet within our
community
and and uh the immigrants because they
were isolated
now i think there's an issue because now
they're going throughout
positive or non-positive they get picked
up and they're
going out and we have no authority to
stop it so when you hear the governors
talking about this being a problem now
for the health and safety of the rest of
america am i hearing right you agree
with that
i totally agree with that
one city over father roy snipes leads
our lady of guadalupe
when we first started it would be the
the the highest number
would be like maybe 200 a day 200. now
it's 300
a pico so that would be like 2100 a week
they were using their empty school house
as a makeshift shelter for the overflow
of families
when one of the migrants tested positive
last week they had to shut down
but with a steady band of volunteers
he's committed to reopening
we've got plenty of beans and we've got
plenty of rice and we've got
we've got plenty of room and we're doing
fine
there's no desire for a solution there
is
but that's beyond me i'm a parish priest
on the south side of mission i'll just
people come and tell me we need food and
we need a place to stay if i could fix
it i would but
that's that's that's a higher science
that i know about
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas will be here on
thursday to talk with local leaders and
to take a look at everything we just
showed you right now
one of the biggest concerns though that
these local leaders have is that they
can provide the shelter they can provide
the food and the kova testing but they
have no authority
to keep anyone here to force anyone to
stay in these facilities
vlad all right midday i thank you very
much